[Applauso]
[Musica]
Ciao ciao
[Applauso]
qui non erano tutti e 70 però insomma ce
n'era una buona parte di tutto quello
che mi è capitato di dover diventare
però dato l'argomento della copia e
dell'originale Volevo fare una premessa
su questi nostri anni siamo Secondo me
alla vigilia se non dentro proprio coi
piedi È tutta una era in cui
falsificare dei filmati delle persone è
diventata anche un po' in qualche modo
pericoloso abbiamo a che fare sempre con
i mezzi questi Social che comunque ci
tengono distanti dalla realtà della
persona fisica con cui confrontarci per
cui mi sono accorto pur essendo non
molto tecnologico Io sono nato negli
anni 60 che specialmente sui social
stanno viaggiando dei filmati in cui non
si sa se quello che vedi è un fatto vero
o de' stato abbiamo creato e riguarda
anche le persone il caso del Deep fake
che è una cosa tecnologica che
conoscerete per cui si fa muovere la
bocca di un personaggio anche magari
importante o influente gli si fanno dire
delle cose e non è lui Ecco potrà creare
inganno già ora lo crea Ma se arriverà
Chissà visto che è un'epoca che ormai
credo non mi riguardi più veramente a
confondere la realtà con la finzione in
maniera totale Io vi porto la mia
esperienza perché è un po' in qualche
modo sebbene lunga che sono 40 anni che
faccio questo lavoro diciamo anche un
po' romantica perché è partita per gioco
anche per talento È partita al liceo al
liceo che ho frequentato un liceo
sperimentale a Livorno in cui mi sono
accorto di avere queste doti no di
replicare delle persone con le voci e
con le movenze e il caso del liceo è
stato un po' Pisignano di quello che poi
mi sarebbe capitato dopo perché avevo
deciso di imitare le voci le movenze
degli insegnanti specialmente quelli più
temuti dai miei compagni di classe il
preside oppure il coordinatore quello
che ti deve interrogare quello che hai
paura che ti Bocci eccetera Cosa accade
allora Che continuando maniacalmente ad
imitarli i miei compagni e presero
confidenza con la copia del
dell'insegnante vero veniva a parlare
con me per scherzare per alleggerire
anche la tensione Perché io gli facevo
vedere un aspetto anche umano di questo
insegnante alla fine mi sono accorto che
questo sistema di replicare una persona
ritenuta pericolosa facendo vedere i
suoi aspetti teneri ebbe un effetto
quasi terapeutico correttivo a fine anno
andavamo tutti più d'accordo con gli
insegnanti i ragazzi erano più
tranquilli e gli insegnanti più cattivi
si presentarono specialmente l'ultimo
anno i più umani Davanti a questa cosa è
nata per gioco ma che ha anche aspetti
psicologici poi ho affinato la mia
attività e l'attitudine a diventare
un'altra persona in tutto e per tutto
sono diventato un imitatore che cercava
di fare delle copie del reale venivo da
la passione per un grande imitatore
trasformista televisivo che si chiamava
Alighiero Noschese che negli anni in cui
c'era solo Rai 1 lo vedevano tutti la
sua carriera è durata solo 11 anni e per
chi è di quella età sembra durata
tantissimo c'era solo lui che replicava
personaggi e invece mi accorsi di
saperlo fare anch'io Allora mi sono
specializzato con i trucchi con anche i
costumi per avere un mio spettacolo da
imitatori trasformisti e camparci l'ho
fatto proprio per lavoro e anche per
passione sono passati una decina d'anni
in cui mi sono accorto che sì lo
spettacolo funzionava perché si vedevano
praticamente una ventina di Grossi
personaggi che mai si sarebbero riuniti
in una serata Quindi potevi avere Vasco
Rossi zucchero Totò tanti personaggi
tutti in una serata e per convincere a
non avere un sottoprodotto Io mi sono
impegnato tanto per essere più identico
possibile a quelli veri Tanto è vero che
il fatto di capire che l'operazione
poteva essere un po' sterile cioè di
fatto sì tu fai le imitazioni di quel
cantante ma non sei lui ti vengo a
vedere ma se è una brutta copia non mi
era mai piaciuta e mi perfezionai al
punto di volermi per forza far dire da
Qualcuno del pubblico a fine serata
dagli impresari cosa che poi è avvenuta
guarda sei più vero di quello vero sei
più tu che ne so Celentano di Celentano
vero Ecco arrivai a quel limite lì che
però mostrava una certa debolezza perché
comunque si trattava sempre di una copia
anche perché stavo per approdare a
Striscia la notizia è un programma che
era ed è tuttora autoale di satira non
poteva accontentarsi di limitazione fino
a se stessa Tant'è vero che Ricci mi
prese nella sua scuderia era 94
Però queste imitazioni fatte con un
breve testo coordinato con gli autori
fatti in TV ferme lì in uno studio
televisivo con dei trucchi che
provenivano dai miei trucchi teatrali
non funzionano per quattro anni io
propose delle imitazioni in una
trasmissione che comunque era
seguitissima e nessuno se ne era accorto
non succedeva niente a un certo punto in
una crisi di proprio di linguaggio
televisivo si decide insieme all'autore
di cambiare strada nacque il personaggio
che cambio anche le sorti di un certo
tipo di fare televisione c'è scendere in
strada e il personaggio fu lo stilista
Valentino il famoso Valentino e il re
della moda decidemmo di mandarlo in giro
con le telecamere
proprio nei luoghi dove poteva trovarsi
anche se lui poi non c'era quasi mai
quindi feste mondane sfilate di moda e
nacque un tipo di televisione per cui
l'imitazione non era poi così tanto
finta Perché la telecamera a spalla e il
vedere come un piccolo telefilm che
accadeva qualcosa con i veri personaggi
invitati a quella serata di gala fece sì
che questo personaggio prendesse una
forza mai vista un'imitazione vivente
tutte le convention le serate di moda le
prime cinematografiche dovettero Fare
conti con le incursioni di questo
Valentino e delle sue telecamere
Ecco che si ribalta però tutta la
situazione da essere un disturbatore e
che metteva in crisi l'organizzazione di
queste serate
diventò una risorsa il successo di
prendere in giro un re della moda
creandone uno identico che però facesse
sorridere fece così che il Valentino di
Striscia non fosse più un'imitazione ma
un personaggio vivente mi sono
immedesimato a tal punto che durante
l'anno una volta su 300 giorni sono
stato Tipo 200 giorni truccato da lui
sono stato più lui che me stesso però
ribaltamento è stato che
dato il successo della televisione per
questi eventi fu fondamentale avere il
finto Valentino di Striscia cioè avere
un volano televisivo che raddoppiasse il
successo di certe manifestazioni
diventava un fiore all'occhiello e una
condizione sine qua no vuoi fare una
serata in vita a Striscia che ti mandano
Valentino così la cosa diciamo assume un
valore ancora più grande ed era una
copia comunque di quello vero che ormai
non esisteva più perché un Valentino che
facesse ridere non esisteva la copia
identica ma buffa esisteva e come la
vedevi tutte le sere o un esempio
clamoroso è stato un evento diciamo
mediatico di quegli anni di costume un
famoso matrimonio tra Eros Ramazzotti e
Michelle Hunziker Matrimonio da sogno
eccetera Cosa accade i vestiti del
matrimonio erano di Armani non di
Valentino e
la coppia di coniugi decise di dare
l'esclusiva televisiva per l'interno
della manifestazione del matrimonio a me
a Valentino di Striscia che fu l'unico
fu l'unico a riprendere l'interno del
matrimonio dove c'era Armani quello vero
ma non c'era Valentino vero c'era il
finto Valentino di ufficio assurdo No
davanti a questo
ribaltamento fu lo stesso Ricci a Dimmi
Guarda tutti i personaggi del tuo
vecchio repertorio se li portiamo in
strada faranno successo Tant'è vero che
per il mondo della musica è Sanremo
venne fuori Gianni Morandi Tony Renis
Gino Paoli Addirittura il figlio di Gino
Paoli mi scambiò per suo padre cioè sono
successe delle cose assurde dopo la cosa
si è sviluppata verso tanti altri
personaggi Non sempre però è affilata
liscio A volte si dice appunto Il potere
della TV e di quanto possa dare fastidio
la copia vivente l'anno in cui imitai
Gianni Morandi lo fece talmente anche lì
tante volte che la cosa sembrò no
aiutare anche la figura la simpatia di
lui eccetera però mi si avvicinò e una
signora del suo ufficio stampa e senza
mezzi termini mi disse Guarda quest'anno
a dire la verità ci sarà il concerto di
Morandi No il tour e ci sarà un disco se
ti limiti un po' a farlo in TV sarà
meglio perché se la gente vede Morandi
in tv invece ero io Eh se la gente vede
Morandi TV poi magari non viene ai
nostri concerti non sbigliettiamo cioè
venne invitato a moderarmi nell'essere
una copia di quello vero altri mondi
parlano del mondo per esempio non della
moda o dello Sport dove avevo fatto
anche Valentino Rossi non hanno gradito
molto per esempio è il caso del cinema
d'autore al festival di canne in Francia
decidemmo di replicare nani Moretti
Nanni Moretti molto amato in Francia io
andai vestito e truccato copia identica
a quello vero
venne scambiato in eurovisione per il
vero amore ed annunciato addirittura
messiena nei morettina sulla Monte dei
marce no sul tappeto rosso Ecco i
francesi si sono indignati non hanno
dimostrato ironia ci hanno cacciati e
siamo diventati ospiti sgraditi e non
tutti le operazioni di questo genere di
una coppia capisco malamente che siano
indolore Per esempio alla vigilia di una
nuova imitazione che poi non ho quasi
mai fatto che era di un altro stilista
che era Roberto Cavalli
prima di farlo siccome cavalli venne a
sapere questa cosa mi avvicino e mi
implorò di non fare la sua imitazione
perché avrebbe creato problemi una copia
così buffa alla sua azienda cioè
collaboratori su vorrei che poi mi
prendessero in giro Ci ho messo tanto a
costruire questo mondo per me è
importante che si era me lo fai crollare
devo dire lì mi sono anche pietosito e
poi siccome Valentino andava forte non
l'abbiamo mai fatto
la volta che invece mi sono ritirato io
è stata il punto di vista diciamo della
delicatezza dell'argomento religioso c'è
stato l'anno in cui ho invitato Papa
Francesco anche lì ci fu una conferenza
stampa a Striscia farlocca dove i ricci
fece finta di essere collegato davvero
col papa che faceva gli auguri per
l'inizio di Striscia Siccome il papa Si
era visto poco si era capito che era uno
diverso dagli altri che andava in giro
così e qui i giornalisti della
conferenza stampa in parte credettero
che davvero Papa Francesco avesse dato
la benedizione dall'inizio di Striscia
no a questo può rientrare nel gioco
perché poi venne svelato io mi accorsi
però che invece fare Papa Francesco
proprio a Roma vicino a Città del
Vaticano creò uno scompiglio non
indifferente Lì c'erano i turisti
stranieri E mi scambiarono per il papa
davvero e sono io che mi sono
autocensurato perché insomma vedere dei
gruppi di fedeli che magari sono
arrivati dall'altra parte del mondo e
sono convinti di aver salutato il papa
io non è che mi sono messa a dire no
sono Quello finto però io l'ho salutati
anch'io Cioè quindi ho creato il loro un
sogno che poi non era vero cioè ho
sentito quello sguardo addosso che può
avere un Fedele verso uno che ritiene un
santo no Quindi lì Mi sono allontanata
Abbiamo smesso di andare magari Vicino a
Città del Vaticano perché sennò sarebbe
stato un guaio comunque Insomma sintesi
finale in questi ultimi anni abbiamo
deciso di veicolare la mia copia
dell'essere uguale ad un altro alla
satira politica finora c'erano sempre
state Bene o male alle vignette vedendo
la caricatura di un personaggio potevano
prendere in giro la politica Ma sul
giornale su un foglio abbiamo quindi
veicolato a Striscia le imitazioni dei
politici per fare della satira davanti a
Montecitorio
limitato un po' tutti
Presidente del Consiglio Renzi Salvini
Conte draghi ma anche Mattarella e tanti
altri e diciamo è stata data una veste
almeno satirica e più auturale a questo
lavoro di replica per fargli accadere
qualcosa alla fine non è che si vanno
tanto a scalfire queste figure politiche
anzi mio malgrado le ho rese più
simpatiche alla fine gli ho fatto quasi
un regalo anche se poi la sateria
cattiva e la battuta è velenosa il fatto
che anche loro sono diventati divini
televisivi gli ha solo raddoppiato la
popolarità quindi in qualche modo è un
mezzo fallimento
Allora per tornare a quella che è stata
invece la mia passione iniziale quella
di replicare soltanto un personaggio o
veicolato in un mondo che non è virtuale
ma è più faccia a faccia e più vicina
alle vibrazioni delle persone che è il
teatro il teatro mi sono permesso di
portare in scena qualcosa che non
sarebbe possibile
confrontare con il vero e faccio due
omaggi importanti uno è quello a Lucio
Dalla che è stato un mio Beniamino
possono diventare amico Lui si è
appassionato ai miei quadri perché io
sono anche pittore quindi racconto la
sua storia ma lo faccio rivivere
valorizzando al massimo le sue canzoni e
spiegandole in modo che possa continuare
la memoria di uno che ancora da scoprire
come artista geniale e della musica e
non solo italiana e do questo omaggio a
Lucio Dalla l'altro Maggio L'ho creato
un po' quasi senza materiale la comicità
italiana è nata
composta da un genio di fine
Ottocento i primi 900 che si chiamava
Ettore Petrolini che ha insegnato un po'
a tutti a Proietti a Montesano a Verdone
al sud ma fino anche ad alcuni
cantautori che usano scioglilingua che
si rifanno a lui Io l'ho sempre studiato
e ci sono materiali audio foto e qualche
video ho ricreato totalmente la sua
figura in modo che almeno essere una
copia voglia dire poter prolungare la
memoria anche culturale di personaggi
che non ci sono più Questo è il mio
contributo non virtuale
nell'essere copia di qualcheduno altri
Spero serva a qualcosa e non danneggiare
o a creare
dei problemi di identità con altri
Grazie
[Applauso]